[Musique]
honoré owendo et je travaille moi je
travaille je travaille des eaux il donc
oui on ne sait pas où je pourrais
trouver des boules par hazard déboule
par hasard met les boules par hasard
whitney absolument tout se soit déroulé
par hasard ah non pas forcément mais
comme c'est introuvable si vous en
trouvez ce sera sûrement par hasard d'un
3 vous aurez du mal entouré de plusieurs
jours à plusieurs sans aucune pourquoi
nous demander s'ils connaissaient un
endroit vous trouvez des boules pas
parce qu'un endroit où il ya des boules
c'est qu'un à plusieurs et alors il y en
a plusieurs je pourrais en trouver une
fois bien sûr quel joueur de boules
cherchez-vous une boule ronde ronde
ronde
c'est un antiquaire format chez les
antiquaires et non des boules d'époque
ah oui vous n'aimez pas la boule
d'époque si j'aime bien la boule
d'époque m'enfin je cherche plutôt à mon
cours entre huit boules la commune à ces
salles à bout d'escaliers par exemple
qu'en france géré par des escaliers chez
moi quand on m'en fait gronder chez vous
pour l'ascenseur les bonnes intentions
n'étant pas neutres pour leur part bien
dans le rôle des partis cherchent une
boule
ah oui c'est vrai mais que pensez-vous
de la boule qui roule en boule qui roule
la boule de pétanque alors je ne veux
pas de boules amusante à ou préfèrent la
boule sérieuse et aux jambes une boule
de naphtaline choisir je préfère la
boule de gomme
oui ma boule de gomme défense efficace
contre limite aussi mais elle est
comestible à usain bolt qui se mange non
pas du tout pas du tout je voudrais une
boule qui durent multi du rhône utile de
parler de la boule de neige inutilisable
en été après moussa chaîne bull pour
l'été a non je traîne bull qui me fasse
au moins toute l'année ah non ça vous
suffit bas reprend supprime donc en
principe pas parfois car louis vachon en
deux une incapable de l'ordinaire pour
quoi faire
quand vous passez l'ordinaire et brassac
en sable et alors et alors là pendant
trudeau d'ordinaire vous savez ça oui
mais leur procès me faut acheter de
boulot il faut deux boules mais non
merci j'ai déjà assez de mal à en
trouver une
même si vous disiez pourquoi vous offre
une boule ça m'aiderait voilà c'est pour
remplacer celle que j'ai cassé a donc
vous en aviez d'une oui j'en avais si
c'était un ami qui me l'avait offert et
vous l'avez et il a trouvé cette année
chez un marchand de mort sur le coup et
la marchande bull va demander à votre
avis là le résume un chamboule n'est
plus de ce monde qui leur chante bull
non mon ami
les marchands de boules n'ya plus en
france où est-il en bulgarie bigre ça
s'arrange pas ah non surtout que c'est à
croire qu'il ya plus de boules en france
170 pour la saison déboule enfin je ne
sais pas tourné avec le marché commun a
pas juste avant justement avez vous
songé aux bulls étrangères oui mais les
bulls étrangères n'ont pas ce petit je
ne sais quoi qui caractérise les boules
française
même les bulldozers un petit nuage c'est
lourd nous allons permettre à vous dire
que question vous est difficile pour
l'enchère conduite amateurs de boules en
bois pas n'importe quel boulot mais
encore faudrait-il savoir l'utilité de
cette boule à ce pur chez moi c'est pas
chez vous c'est pour chez moi donc j'ai
des goûts l'intérieur c'est ça c'est ça
une moule l'intérieur mais qu'on puisse
sortir
oui la boule familiale en quelque sorte
le groupe familial
les duels tout dépend de la façon dont
on s'en sert comptez vous en servir
souvent chaque fois que j'en aurai
besoin oui alors en somme si j'ai bien
compris c'est davantage la boule
utilitaire que les boules décoratives
c'est ça plutôt la ville utilitaires
mais alors simple pratique hygiénique
pas sa licence et facile à entretenir
facile entretenir ses mots alors la fois
que vous aurez du mal à retrouver à
bascule si j'ai bien compris ce que vous
cherchez et la boule l'utilitaire facile
andreu dire c'est la boule de luxe et la
boule de luxe n'est pas facile
d'entretenir voyez aujourd'hui certains
il dans un jeu ne savait pas où je
pourrais trouver des cubes par hasard
[Musique]